alors ce soir on est au 2e Grand Prix
Rav championnat de la réunion sous les
figie d'AVB donc l'Internationale
fédération de bodybuilding on entend par
bodybuilding maintenant beaucoup de
catégories comme le men's physique le
bikini le body fitness
le wom's physique donc on est là pour on
a à peu près h catégories h grosses
catégories pour 65 athlètes un record à
la Réunion donc ça s'est jamais vu et
c'est un peu le le travail la rançon du
travail bien fait de de la dernière
année et le bodybuilding a toujours son
public donc effectivement le public est
très demandeur et beaucoup plus
demandeur ces dernières années alors
pour la plupart ça ça représente une
année de travail hein en body building
en surtout les catégories là où le le
développement musculaire est le plus
probant donc ensuite en M physique en
bikini ça quand même ça demande quand
même des sacrifices alimentaires et
autres donc voilà effectivement ça la
plastique demande
énorme
beaucoup
d'investissements physique pour le par
rapport aux entraînements qui au début
sont assez soft et plus on avance dans
l'aventure et plus ça devient difficile
et puis investissement au niveau du
mental donc faut vraiment s'accrocher et
puis vouloir se donner à 200 %. je suis
sportive depuis toujours donc mais
c'était vraiment une passion et j'ai
voulu mettre mais la compétition euh en
action pour voilà exceller dans ma
passion j'ai vraiment je me suis donnée
à fond il y a 5 mois j'ai commencé
vraiment le gros entraînement il y a 5
mois je pense que en une demi-année on
peut déjà avoir de très très bons
résultats
on a un très très bon niveau on a amené
13 athlètes au championnat de France au
mois d'avril au Mureau à Paris sur 13
athlètes qu médailles d'or deux
médailles d'argent et des sélections
pour l'Arnold classique des compétitions
prestigieuses et pour Europe donc oui
les réonnaés un très bon
niveau